- [Voiceover] Here are some things
men may not know about their clothes.
The Boat Shoe was invented by Paul Sperry.
The sole of the shoe was
modeled after his dogs paw;
the dog has no memory of this.
Men who wear Bow Ties are
seen as older, smarter,
brainier, and Republicaner.
This button was inspired by
polo players who'd put buttons
on their collars to keep them
from flying up while playing.
While we're on the subject of polo,
Polo Shirts were created
for tennis, not polo.
But, back to buttons on collars.
Shirts with button-down collars
are called button-down shirts,
but shirts that button in the front
and don't have button-down collars
are called button-front
shirts, not button-downs.
The triangle on the front
of some sweatshirts,
was originally put there as
extra fabric to absorb sweat.
The YKK that is on all of your zippers
stands for Yoshida Kogyo Kabushikikaisha.
And women shirts button on
the opposite side as men's,
because women used to
be dressed by servants,
and this way the button would
be in the servants right hand,
as it is for men dressing themselves.
One in eight men surveyed
confessed to wearing their
underwear two to three
times between washes,
and three of three people we just surveyed
said, "Eww," after hearing that.
(lively drums)